hi guys my name's Ian Cooper and
hopefully you've come to hear me talk
about service consumer Pat's so just a
brief idea on what our service consumer
Pat's so if you've built your micro
services architecture one of the things
you're going to have to come to terms
with is how your clients or partners are
actually going to communicate with those
micro services and this talk is about
the challenges that you face moving from
worldly use doing monoliths to the world
of micro services when you want to
actually go so today we're going to
start talking about a little bit of a
very short gif in just refresh our
memory of how we did this in the world
of monoliths and we'll look at two
separate ideas how we issued commands to
our system and nothing earth-shaking
here we all understand that just for
context and then we'll look at why the
changes we make with micro services will
have a tiny bit about what a micro
service is why that we then get a
challenge with micro services in using
these same strategies and then we'll
tackle the problems in two parts look
where is first of all how we compose
queries to our monoliths and we'll look
at commands how we actually issue
requests to our micro services to do
things a lot to get through so we'll
have to move fast and we have a little
tiny summary most of the slides
unimportant just as I'm old at the point
I really try and draw attention to is
the one at the bottom everybody really
can get into speaking and actually you
know nowadays with the pandemic that's
probably lots of opportunities to do a
little short talks at user groups around
the world so please do it helps you get
your head around topics if you have to
teach them and once you get over that
initial hurdle there it's really a great
experience um I work on an open source
project called brighter we deal with
messaging in the donor - world so kind
of CTRs approaches we're always looking
for new contributors you can
this essentially by just searching for
brighter command and you know what
you'll find us really easily or just
afterwards um um this talk is one of
kind of a pair so last year and you see
I talked a bit about event-driven
collaboration there's a tiny bit of
crossover in concepts but I won't dig
into too much detail on some of those
ideas in this presentation and if you're
interested just by see a signpost that
you can go and see my last NDC talk for
more of a deep dive on some of those
ideas alright so the first thing I want
to stop talking about is what are the
old world or for some of you it still is
the current one correct so what is a
model that from a perspective from a
spectacle monolith is really something
where when we talk about deployment we
talk about deploying everything within
the system boundary usually the
constraint that makes that I think the
monolith has to do is the fact that we
have one shared database and occurs a
change to the schema in that database
can require happen to affect any number
of actual components which taught the
database then we end up with basic idea
of a monolith now it may be that we are
able to say oh actually I don't have to
release every single thing in a model if
I only have to release the things that
are impacted by the schema change but
what happens is in my experience we end
up with release meetings we all sit
around discussing that we found everyone
impacted by this change we need to apply
to staging something breaks and staging
and you have to go back and figure out
or worse as it breaks in production and
what that means is that the cadence of
our recently slows and I quite often see
this happening in most places I've
worked in a kind of two weeks release
cycle to get things out the door which
means that eventually by comparison to
your competitors you could be releasing
multiple times a day this can be a
problem it's also much harder for
multiple teams because all these teams
continually have to coordinate their
releases one of the things we're trying
to show here is that you might actually
have components running in different
containers
you might have four or five api's that
are all hosted on separate parts of
yours AIAS or in separate Kestrel or
separate basically django websites
whatever whatever your flavor is because
they're all sharing a database they all
have this constraint that they have to
be released under a single boundary
let's imagine a world that are
essentially harness and components it's
probably or released as kind of one big
website and were we don't something that
dealt with Hotel software now I
apologize to everybody who may actually
in dealt with Hotel software at some
point in their life because I don't I
just use it as an example because
because I know nothing about Hotel
software I can move away from the
details and most of us have some
experience for checking into a hotel
understand so in the old world I might
have a kind traditional that I've got my
API my domain model which is nicely
modulized on this not pejorative term
just a description of certain
characteristics it has with my big
database at the bottom and potentially
I've got some more am feeding data and
let's imagine the situation where I
wanted to make a hotel booking as an
existing customer that held that an
account with your business that's so
getting the work done for a command I
decide basically to post my new booking
it comes in by the API liner from
whatever client I'm using our
application or something and then
effectively what would tend to happen is
I would create a new booking using the
direct bookings module I've got some you
know types in there I can crank stuff
with and then probably I would save that
early formal in booking saying I had a
tentative new booking to the database
farm I don't like knowing time in terms
of my business logic that I now need is
your account information that's why I
held the credit card details I was going
to submit those to my payment system so
I'd then read from the database and get
your account details back by the ORM and
having got your account details
indicating the credit card information
then submit the credit payment system
credit card payment system or probably
cause some kind of external a payment
provider like PayPal etc and once we've
got a message back send your credit card
had sufficient funds tellurium I
probably then talked to the housekeeping
system and said I'd like to reserve a
room this customer on this date
housekeeping with it then write to the
database and say let's store that
particular room reservation and then we
might talk to a channel manager so
channel managers will talk booking.com
and Expedia and says we have a number of
rooms available with this range of
prices we may update our channel manager
hey this rooms are really in demand
right now so that's basically up the
prices and again let me talk to some
external basically site to get actual
those channels and of course you've got
to get the list of channels from the
database as you can see it's a fairly
straightforward source of interactions
because we can just reach into database
at any time that we need to fulfill the
next step in the workflow
I mean update the booking at the end on
a query well let's assume I want to
basically assume that me bill you know
do some laundry
let's assume we've decided to go for a
kind of CTRs model we're not going to go
through our entity model in the domain
you know to basically get some data back
like for example you walk in you up head
up to the front desk you want to check
in I want to get up your details if
you're booking the room reservation and
maybe some information from your account
so I can determine effectively some
personal preferences that you wants up
in your room or I hope to make sure I
call you by the right now and then the
simple CTS model I've just got some kind
of query layer effectively which I can
then use to go and pull the data I need
to have the database join it together
and present some nicely prepared to you
back on screen for the user sitting
basically check-in desk at the hotel
alright so let's talk about how this
picture changes once we get into the
world of micro services so first a short
version of what my definition of my
predecessor so I come from an SOA
background
I tend to think micro-services is kind
of SOA through yesterday's events
estimated one with web services and it
has some additional constraints coming
from the man driven design from DevOps
even from things like rest and guru
duress away which is quick Jim Weber and
all those are essentially created a
series of additional constraints to help
team like us so this is desperate but I
can think of a micro service or
something that has an additional four
tenets it has an explicit boundary in
other words you can't reach in and talk
to my data you have to go over an AP on
the API could be HTTP GRP C it could be
messaging it could be M key peak after
etc point it's autonomous
that means I release everything
insulators for hungry together
now I also release everything inside the
boundary together and I'm but here my
system consists of a number of smaller
pieces called micro services that are
independently deployable which means
that actually under playing the smaller
part and Germany 18 has got off an
orange its are owning a micro service so
the team now controls its own release
cadence and we get to great ideas like
products not projects will skip schema
not talking incompatible in that policy
because it's not important to the
conversation but we owner whether
signature of that data nobody else can
like that dota they have to come through
our API didn't and in terms of what
partition strategy we choose how many of
these these things to get I still have a
believer in the kind of SOI approach
which says we're aligned to a business
process right and so there are various
ways of doing that I have a separate
talk which you can see okay but NDC
London the basic but general you want to
slice our system up into business
processes and the line using micro
socity processes so imagine this is what
a hotel look like in terms of slicing
business processes it may not do I don't
know don't build your fortune on this so
imagining we basically said very similar
to our modules in fact in our model
where we had a direct bookings micro
service credit card payments micro
service accounts housekeeping a channel
matching like receptors how do we now
run those same scenarios we're looking
at earlier in our new exciting micro
services world
when we think about commands my commands
what I mean is we issue some
instructional requests to the backend
micro service to update something to
change something to carry out some work
for example and making a hotel booking
one of the questions is going to become
how does that work actually hat so this
is a typical kind of layout I might have
for a microt service you can see we've
got a bus down the bottom so our micro
services tend to be integrated by an
asynchronous communication protocol
using some kind of messaging transport
so Kathy a rabbit and you ask us an S
and s as the SOS bus whatever your
flavor choices and my individual
services essentially listen for events
on the bus and that's how we've chosen
to do most of our interrupt because they
gives us nice benefits like we're
decoupled in terms of time and behavior
from other parts of the system and above
them I've got some kind of gateway tool
and we'll come into more detail on what
that is later but that's some kind of
layer which says I need to access
potentially one or more micro services
at a time okay and I've got potentially
partners and clients you want to talk to
my micro services so imagine that same
scenario again where I want to basically
crater and you looking for a hotel well
I see now what's going to happen I call
the API to take a direct booking but how
am I actually going to start the work of
doing the other steps in my flow getting
my credit card information out of the
account taking the payment reserving the
room with housekeeping updating the
channel manager because direct bookings
has its data about booking but it
doesn't have the data that lives in the
other micro services and the rules
I can't reach into their database you
can get hold of their data so I need
some other mechanism to base it you
interesting ask them what to do or
rather give them instructions what to do
so the obvious answer I might reach for
is well they've all got an API just like
everything else so I can just use their
API from the crime so I could call my
accounts micro service and say hey well
credit cards and I could take the credit
card details and I could
say hey propane service please take a
payment on this credit card it would
then talk to basically the reserving of
a room it's a place reserved the room
for me and then essentially after the
dive update the channel match and that
seems quite promising but there are a
couple of little details that we need to
think about this the first is we've
essentially built an old-school
client-server mode all of the business
logic now lives in my clients not
actually in my micro services and that
can be difficult because it means
whatever I want to update my workflow I
have to update the client my client has
become smart and my actual services have
become quite them and this leads us to
basically a problem called
an entity service we don't want our
micro services to just be focused on
entities so if you create a micro
service which is literally doing crud
operations on a single entity or even an
aggregate that effectively you keep
updating your problem is the business
logic which ought to live with the micro
services has now drifted out to the
client so Catina wants to effectively
change how the booking process works in
terms of their aspect of it they may
struggle or they've got control over is
crap all the pressures going to be on
the front end to you which continually
has to update the workflow whenever any
changes happen and in the downstream
systems so that top model basically the
identity services is regarded this with
a quite anti pan and Michael Miller the
guy right release it has a really good
blog post about entities there's
probably more I share the slides I get
the anything to the bottom read that a
much better model is to remember their
micro senses and focused on processes
the form part of our customer journey or
part of our operational support for
customer journeys we think about that we
can say really what we want to do is
have a new booking process which handles
all the last place in the booking and
then effectively passes the torch onto
reservations and positive thoughts on
payments and passes the torch onto
channel manager so that effectively we
have a flow of information through our
system dealing with the bookie and then
we can keep the business rules that
apply to that particular process with
the data of that process all inside on
micro-service the other problem is if we
think about it we're gonna make a series
of rules here so let's say our post
picks a couple hundred milliseconds I'll
get a hundred or credit card payment
takes a lot longer because essentially
we have to make a call to an external
provider and they usually take forever
to basically service our requests
housekeeping well we're just doing a
quick post maybe that's okay
and channel manager again we're in this
world where essentially but probably
making an external call to Expedia
booking.com we may be making a series of
calls and effectively the light at the
scene is gonna build that and so for our
individual user sitting in front of
their computer or on their phone looking
at the client there's going to be quite
a waiting if it's in a browser so we're
going to be the people who put the
message up so please don't navigate away
from this page right now we might say
well some of these operations can be
done asynchronously but we still have an
end-to-end process to complete here
which is being run by the client so that
that again doesn't seem like the best
solution for us
all right let's switch to a track and
look at the problems we're going to get
with queries and our microscope as well
so just part your thoughts about
commands will come back and we'll
explain how we solve some those problems
in a bit well now let's basically have a
look at queries one of the problems we
get the queries well queries might might
seem a lot easier so let's essentially
you turn up Hotel and you're go to the
front desk and you say my name is mr.
Cooper I should be booked into this
lovely hotel and porch well cuz I'm
staying here for nd seaport oh and a
lovely career NB C would have booked me
into my Portuguese hotel and they look
for my booking and the system is really
gonna have to go baby poverty and talk
to things like direct bookings account
and housekeeping get that data and this
seems much more straightforward I can
just use the API to get hold of all the
data that I need in order to basically
service your request but again very mind
and effective
I'm now but a super amount of latency
and cool in that request is there a
better way of doing that is calling all
three of those services and then as the
client taking all that data munging it
together myself eventually before I can
display is that the best approach or
other other alternatives which means
more efficient and again we'll talk
about those and overall I think of this
problem at micro service I sometimes
abstract is called get the join problem
right before we had a single database
and it was really easy for us and we
were querying to joindota between two
tables in order to basically produce
basically something like that said Ian's
booking information for the front desk
once we came through our micro services
because every micro service is now
managing a portion of the data that we
have gonna be how old joining now
becomes harder because we're actually
doing that by see far HTTP across
multiple micro services all right so
let's have a look at some kind of
solutions that we think we can you used
to so some of these problem so we'll
start with reads and then we'll move
into commands that's my electric some
water okay right so here's that kind of
model again let me talk about a gateway
layer and they talked about a number of
things is being so when we talk about
gateways did the API gateways
some of us tend to think to ourselves oh
that's off-the-shelf product that I can
deploy in AWS that essentially sits in
front of my service except for Anderson
load balancing and routing and I want to
avoid that combat that kind of concept
gateway from me here is basically I
think is a layer that sits over on micro
services and marriage is essentially
some of the interaction we have with
that so we're all process managers for
time being just focus on keeping like
gateways and BFFs on that alright so
what happens when I check in we said
when I check in I'm going to want to go
and get some data all right I'm going to
probably want to go east check on the
account information yet
my personal details back perhaps even
the credit card I've got on file so they
can check with that and I got over our
check with the housekeeping system about
my room reservation and so naively we
want to say well the simple answer here
is that I essentially just call
basically accounts and housekeeping
actually and I say maybe I start with
basically accounts and I say go and find
mr. peepers account information and then
see what bookings he's got he's one of
the day I could do it the other way
around and say that's going for
reservations on this date and then I'll
pull in the account details for the
matching account order we might think
what I'm gonna do is just compose that
information basically into calls
occurred but maybe another alternative
and that is the rather making that other
call I could potentially just return it
in 180 icon and this comes up a lot when
people start to compare rest for the
grass to well people say oh the problem
with the rest is I always have to make
multiple calls because I my rest based
service only owns don't if I kind of one
microservice and that doesn't
necessarily have to actually be true so
let me take you through the journey of
an idea called reference there's a
reference there's an idea Microsoft
wrote a number of papers which is very
useful if I understanding how to build
successful service oriented
architectures what we need to understand
for the point of view or reference later
is that you said earlier that my service
essentially owns data and it's the
single writer of that data and it has an
explicit boundary right but the reality
is when I call their service to say yes
and booking you for much and data leaves
my service and travels outside that
there is now an on the wall and a piece
of data which refers to something inside
and one percepts and it has a number of
important characteristics right the
first is that that data essentially is
stale as soon as it leaves basically
that system becomes stale because
someone could come in and update the
booking information and then I can see
well I'm working on affectively to get
that they've got previously has slightly
out of date data
so quite often we tend to do is have
some kind of personal timestamp on the
data so we can tell how current is they
actually said last modified rather than
it what a wide sense really
but with saying basically here's a date
and timestamp reduce that so you can
check on hoc but most current current
one and cache-control have been
indicated for how long we thought it was
safe to keep using this version before
it was likely someone else an updated or
changed it's also effectively immutable
there's no point in you changing the
information get back as a result they
get requests it doesn't actually update
the booking information the only way to
change the booking information is by an
API called the direct booking service
itself and then things it doesn't have
to be HTTP messages it could actually be
an event that I've raised and that event
itself may have some information on it
and that may include things that again
like the version basically all the
booking information just receive all of
that data we tend to call the outside
data and we tend to call the data in the
side service the inside now the really
interesting thing about outside data is
it's highly casual both I mean from it
comes from basically you get which we
used to Kashi any different information
I pick up on a messaging from another
system is also very highly cache and we
talk about this more in the vendor and
collaboration talk but the idea to think
about here is this if I was to cool with
your cats system regularly to get your
account details how it might think to
myself I could cache that API call and
store your account information so that
effectively next time I needed it you'd
be able to get hold of it the trouble is
of course generally speaking I might
have traditionally given hotel once
twice a year and so it's very unlikely
I'm gonna get cash
it's Pacey when you tell up at the front
desk but if I could pre-build the cash
such that effectively when you turned
out your data was already in the cache
well then that might be a way of
avoiding me having to make the call
across to the account says so this leads
this idea called event card state
transfer
I think the same human actually pulls a
data pump and I've also seen a cool
reference data by Jim Weber and Robin
sitting there but rest in practice
the idea is that what I could do is
listening to events from the account
system and I assume that the account
system produces an event anything
changes in the world of accounts so for
example I changed my dress I changed my
credit card to update because y'all
weren't boasting was out of date I
changed my name for example whenever any
of those happen what happens is
housekeeping is listing to those events
and it's building in a cache of
information it needs about accounts so
generally speaking it's probably storing
my postcode my credit card etc details
it's able to keep building up that cash
in response to events and that means
when effectively housekeeping basically
is asked well can you get me the account
information let's attach this
reservation details it can actually
attach account information to that
reservation so rather than simply having
to go make the second cool-lookin so
generally when we get a reservation we
also tend to give you the last four
digits of the credit card the customers
postcode and date of birth
you can check it's really damn when
we're asking them a couple of simple
questions when they get to the front
desk and I can return that in the
original response I'm now making one
cool very common use of this is if I
store product IDs and I want to attach
the product description so I work at
just E some of you may know so if I've
got a menu ID attached to an order and I
want to attach the description of the
menu item if I had a local cache
basically order at menu date so I could
then attach to rather than description
rather than calling a separate service
to obtain that data and I can read that
customer info and that means I turn that
into a one call rather than essentially
- all right let's like a more
complicated scenario let's say what I
want to do is measure the effectiveness
of my given channels so what I want to
do I have manager sitting there and I'm
trying to find out how much I sell
through booking how much through speedy
how much through Google and whatever the
services are the aggregators so probably
what I want to do is look in my system
and say hey if I meet channel group for
each channel the data that belongs to
the individual
bookings and give me a summary of how
many bookings I had per quarter which
from each of those channels and again
naively my approach might be well I'm
gonna call the channel manager at list
of channels back and maybe I was seen
when my booking information has an idea
of a channel they're basically made a
booking and then I will pull back a list
of bookings and then somewhere in my
code I will essentially do all the
grouping of that data between the
channel manager bookings
don't forget whereas previously I might
have done this like wearing my database
and relying on sequel to actually group
up all the summary information for me at
this point if I'm doing in a partner is
going to be client code running in the
partner that effectively has to
basically do all the grouping and take
all the booking information spit out the
report that seems kind of an effective
right because they've sent to our
Neutral the business logic for quoting
that report and to some consumer of
these two API so what can I do to solve
that problem well the answer looks very
similar so if I take this notion of
event care estate transfer I can say
what happened a minute my booking
service and my channel manager service
are constantly creating events so if I
add a new channel manager or a movie
channel manager etc then effectively I'm
going to have an event so I could listen
to those in a list of channel managers
and then Alessio booking I could say
when that booking comes in I'm going to
basically aggregate under that channel
manager the number of bookings that moon
a total value the bookings etc I can do
that per quarter so I'm listening to
those events over time I'm building
essentially a database that gives me the
reporting information I need and that
channel director database can be written
in such that effectively my query from
my API is a very simple cool that
probably just reads a row out of the
database that's very fast and efficient
some folks call this a composite view
model where essentially we are building
a model that can answer given query
questions for a consumer and discussion
a reference data refers this is the
Oracle artifacts when you think about
something like a data Lake in your
enterprise quite often data lakes are
just really large
Gale worsens right you were duped Lakers
caught off a listing to all the events I
know beyond microscopes building a
complex model to do analytics against
but even a really simple level it can
help you essentially build responses to
particular front-end queries okay so
it's a really easy one to do and it's
very effective at building fast report
plug information and again when people
talk about growth key well versus rest
you know one of the things they miss is
that if you understand what report
you're going to build it's very easy to
do that with rest provided you can kind
of pre build the data that you need to
answer the question with or when we have
some fancy animation behold my animation
here me okay all right because water
all right I saw my Jennifer Connor
scenario and I'm gonna basically push
this scenario a little bit just we get a
different example let's imagine that I
want to basically search for going to
stay in Portugal and kill a hotel brand
I pick has three or four different
actual hotels important and imagine this
you know that Radisson has Madison blue
different you know sort of budget and
tree it's got a luxury entry maybe put
some boutique brands etc and I'm going
to their site I want to know what's the
range of things that you offer me okay
so I'm typing this information so we're
about to go and visit it and I want you
to give me answer all your properties
and let's imagine for the minute that
the nature of this information is the
only real time because booking is a big
conference happening in porto booking is
a happening rapidly and it may well be
that i want to get information the thing
about the last example we saw that tends
to be often used where the flow of
change is sufficient you're probably
talking about a rollup that happened
doesn't matter if you see data that's
basically you know a little bit old
would buy eventually a few minutes or so
because messages are started in no one
there because generally it's a it's a
position of data that is indicative
rather than has to be exactly right so
imagine here that the data is changing
very fast now actually you can use the
composite view model to solve a lot of
these problems because you're courted
processing your data fast enough to keep
poking the opposition search but let's
imagine we can't let's imagine product
manager is essentially put his foot down
and said no no i must have real time but
your real time booking information so
the particular case the problem I've got
is that I need to go to direct booking I
need to go to property services but I
can't pretty build the view of what I've
got and this tends to be where you
really do need to do actual composition
in a gateway layer to say I'm gonna call
both these services I'm going to combine
the data together
so what we
who is have some kind of gateway but API
that essentially says I provide the API
line for hotel group search you call me
I've got my own REST API of Britain and
I will internally then make the cause of
direct booking of proxy services and I
will then manage that they could
together to show that a customer by
whatever I to really put in basically
what hotels are available right now in
Porto given you know they said I don't
want budget and you want you know luxury
and boutique hotels spending to them now
so why is this kind of gateway well if
you think about people like originally
with a kind of pioneers of this kind of
model this API in Java and their Java
API effectively sat over their actual
flying graining the SOA their micro
services and made the calls directly to
them and so this little air ax is the
one that gives the API that basically
joins data across multiple micro
services now as I said before I wouldn't
go to this if you can solve the problem
it's just a simple problem of what we
need to have is some additional operand
data which just says what is the
customers address what if the what if
the customers credit card number I do
that five main cast a transfer and if I
needed a composite few more like a pre
figure out the query I might want do
that but this model says I'm gonna do it
in real time answer and you can think of
this basically layer as a proxy it's a
proxy that sits between you and the
micro service APL and manages those
calls and that has some kind of
interesting characteristics it's not
just usable as a composite API or BFF
BFF basically you really uses samstone
if it was really one of these built for
a specific client so BFF says actually
I'm gonna build one of these but it's
gonna return data in just a shape around
or a client needs it or just a shape
that this third party organization wants
that data as opposed to an open a
gateway generic which is based
generic gateway that I can use for any
number of clients and the reason you
might do the more tailored version is to
basically make sure that you're not
returning unnecessary data to the
consumer so you can minimize the cost
over the wire and given this piece of
data I give this proxy letter in the
gateway I could say wanting to honest
with you I put some other things in here
this is what Netflix did with mr. it's
right it said you know what given that
I'm now temporarily coupled to any of
these micro services it's possible that
I get some transient network error
talking to the virus TTP it's possible
that for some reason the instance I know
the load balancer sends me to initially
is bad and I notice how they're going to
go to another one and I can do things
like do a retrial
I can circuit breaker just stop going to
things that are bad for a temporary
period and maybe when I do that I can
serve cached results because maybe the
hotel the bookings haven't changed I
don't have to worry about that I can
rate limit here or I can say effectively
I'm getting too many requests because
everyone wants to travel to Porto so I'm
gonna tell my clients to slow down with
the requests I'm receiving and I can
load balanced at this layer across a
range nobody so this is what we tend to
get into the notion of API gateways as a
product that would do something because
I can have all these useful additional
properties that I start managing the
layer of the Gateway itself which are
kind of like your thorgan onto its role
in being a place that's combining
providing a new API which makes coolster
are micro services but actually become
part of the requirement for you when you
start to say I need to call four or five
microscopes just return the result and
therefore I have a more complex problem
of saying or are now dependent on three
things so the availability of my service
is dependent on multiple application of
avail of the essays of all of those
three items and trying to manage that
result or with things that retry circuit
breakers etc all right that's talking
about reads so roughly just kind of
remember their event care estate
transfer could help you solve a lot of
problems why affecting the
letting you bring in the additional data
you need to make your restaurant
slightly more informative or less your
build ahead of times and kind of come
visit you won't have to answer the
question if not you may need to go to
kind of composition at the gate where
we're about conversations about rights
okay so imagine that I want to now
handle a comment on this architecture so
I want to place you create a new booking
we looked at that that was the kind of
first example we looked at so I'm saying
hey a new booking comes in I'm gonna
write that basically to my direct
bookings and bookings is gonna then
raise a message is we've got nice
asynchronous communication between our
micro-services saying a new booking has
been married and what we want to happen
is that the customer gets charged for
that information that charge of that
booking and then we basically reserve
the room and housekeeping in a channel
manager what happens now effectively if
I like try and take payment the problem
is gonna be that I end up in a world
where the credit card payments doesn't
have the account details for the
customer to get the credit card
information so how do I get ahold of
that credit card information because the
bookings just come in right when I count
and I don't seem to have it how would I
get hold of it a naive me what happens
in a lot of people when they're
discussing kind of how micro services
work is they say oh once you've received
notifications
make a call to accounts bar accounts API
to get the credit card information it's
actually the problem with this is that
earlier on we said we wanted a nice
asynchronous communication between our
micro services over the past because we
what we wanted some benefits of
decoupling both temporarily in other
words they don't have to be app and in
terms of behavior we don't have
knowledgeable the other thing cause you
have to make will just recalled a
similar feature I'm reaching to account
to get hold of that data so how do we
solve that problem so there are two main
solutions and we can think of these
basically and being both being push
models in the left hand side we can see
a model where were saying well the
obvious solution should be to make sure
that time
which is credit card payments we have
all the data we need to make a payment
in that message and so the question is
well how do I get a hold of that data
how I get over the credit card data from
the customers account to pass the credit
card payments basically when it comes in
the second option is I have some kind of
cash of the account data so if the
credit card payments simply says I can
answer that question myself already have
the credit card customer looking at I
solve both those problems so
choreography is the name we tend to give
to the idea of having a pipeline living
through which a message flows when we
receive basically a request to do
something flow that taking a request for
a pipeline of services that all take a
hand in delivery why is it called
choreography well I tend to think of it
this way when people perform a dance
that's actually a choreographer is there
beforehand and helps them basically
figure out what the dance will then look
like but in the actual performance the
choreographers not really present
directing things the dancers essentially
are on their own and in the same way
while you may design at design time the
actual relationship of all the events
they're going to flow through your
system to make work happen in this
particular case the customer journey of
making a booking there's nobody actually
controlling that process in this model
what we do is we simply look at the good
old pipeline approach right so a
pipeline essentially says I have a
source and a sink there's someone who
originates the actual workflow someone
basically is the final step in the
workflow and in between I may have an
arbitrary number of steps that I pass
through okay and this is a very common
approach to messaging is to use
pipelines to solve problems so my direct
booking comes in to my direct booking
service it doesn't have the credit card
details that I need but what actually
listens to direct booking made is going
to be the account system in the account
system when it picks it up is going to
say I know that when I
the rep booking is what life is
iron-rich the content of that message
with credit card details we tend to
refer to spam as a content in richer it
has the credit card details and it may
erase a message saying for example new
booking with credit card details and
that's what credit card payments then
listens to is that other message which
effectively means it now has basic
booking details with the credit card
information it needs take the booking
from the customer and that pipeline
approach would enriching the data such
that the person needs to action it is
actually quite a common way of solving
problems okay so what happens if there's
an error in this model what happens if
credit card payments basically can't be
enacted because errors in pipelines for
additional problem that Pienaar catches
what happens if I can arrow down to with
the end well the simple answer with
choreography is the credit card payments
micro service raises an event saying
there was basically insufficient funds
or whatever Arab or credit card has
expired
it raises a credit card payment and new
bookings essentially Kevin listen to
that error and say hey there was an
error rise that gets the credit card
payment that is bookie I'm going to
suspend the booking and then it may in
return now say hey when I suspend the
booking what I'm doing is issue a
message so that effectively we can begin
the process of contacting the customers
last and present you card details and so
I'm going to raise a message that goes
to accounts so that accounts can enrich
the that message with the customer
contact information and then that can
then appear effectively or our other
service in somebody's in inbox that
actually action calling the customer and
trying to basically get a new credit
card details are even sending an email
to the customer to ask them basically to
represent their credit Kentucky just in
the certain time and that's choreography
and the real advantage of choreography
is that we retain this event based model
and the event based model says I has the
publisher I have no awareness of my
subscribers I simply know that
effectively my job is to publish these
events and that other people take action
and that means we have a lot of
decoupling between our systems the
disadvantage is that it's very hard for
anyone to understand what state is this
booking in as a traditional problem with
the plant will and architects you read
about classic architecture pans one of
the things that comes out people say
it's pretty unclear for feedback to the
user at what point they're in the in the
pipeline their particular request is no
an answer in Portland I'll take
something called a wire tap
so wire tap says I sit and I listen to
all the messages flowing down the wire
and then effectively I can keep updating
what state the order is and where is it
reached how it's currently getting the
account details
oh it's reach credit card payments and
is trying to take credit card payment oh
it's raised in error and basically it's
the booking has been suspended and
generally that piece of data you just
wrap an API over effectively in somebody
then basically in your help desk can
always then dial in with the booking ID
and figure out where the given basic
transaction is um and for example that
just eat that's very common way of us
figuring out where your order is but if
you're kind of unhappy with that model
of just having kind of some monitoring
going on you may want destruction or
just another couple of benefits of about
a second the orchestration is the model
that there is a conductor there are
somebody controlling the whole orchestra
as they begin to actually move through
this for this journey of conducting work
and so with orchestration I may use this
idea of a process management now also
folks called a saga we don't really want
to get into whether solder is a good
name or not solder and particularly in
the dotnet community is the word if one
tends to use this but essentially I'm
running there's actually something that
has multiple steps that I need to
process generally speaking from really
either process manager essentially
always delivers outside the mind
processes right some people put it in
the initial microservice I think the
problem with that is you move the
workflow into one Micra so this is a bit
of a lie you have a photo blips thermal
some of the work that's what happens
with this model is the process manager
basically gets told we're going to make
a booking the process manager effective
released or something his database which
says I am now running this particular
booking workflow it has an ID for that
and then it sends a message right
generally basically you can use
messaging to do this you don't have to
basically engage certain P you can use a
request response pattern in messaging
and what happens they send a message to
booking is that I say effect hey I've
got an e but here's a new booking
request booking this goes away and
satisfies that and makes the booking and
an effective way does is it responds to
me with information about that booking
what tends to happen is I tend to give
you a private channels for applying I'm
not interesting everybody listening to
booking responses I have some private
channel what often advertised the
address of that whatever format I'm
using AMQP or an SNS at one topic and
say okay you should reply here and then
effectively you reply back with another
message and I've picked that up and when
I pick it up I say okay booking work for
that I'm interested in I woke up and
look at it and say okay now what the
direct booking next of my workflow is to
gather the critical information so again
I send that message towards basically
the account system and I say please can
you give me back the credit card details
and in the again effectively it then set
it and raises a message saying here are
the credit card details this particular
booking workflow I listen to that I wake
up my particular workflow and I add the
credit card details there and you can
see on the top left hand corner we were
affected this is command oriented rather
than the previous one for your photos
event oriented that's because our
process manager tends to know that
system it's talking to is going to
handle those messages and give it a
response back we have much tighter
coupling here between the process
manager and the individual steps that is
dealing and then finally what may happen
is basically I say okay let's basically
send my enriched booking message which
has the credit card details etc routed
lead to this there's a payment right and
I can take the payment that comes back
another word for that
says great I am now done I have to have
reserved the room for the customer and
in return poured in what it does is
essentially it then says I'm going to
now update basically direct bookings and
tell it basis we're not showing here
tell it basically took the booking
basically as as complete what that gives
us essentially is a view of the process
the whole time you can always ask the
process manager what's what what state
it's in now we haven't really got any
significant advantages at this point
over using choreography and we've
actually got more confidence so I might
want to do that so generally it is to do
with how we manage errors in the
choreography model what happens if for
example if I can't take a payment is
that my credit card payment service
raises an event saying couldn't take the
payment but there's not necessarily a
guarantee that we're going to actually
basically terminate that booking because
I have to rely on the message I mean
guarantee delivery to basically the
booking service to pick it up and get
all of that information I'm just raising
event I don't even know if there's a
booking service he's gonna listen to it
so in circumstances where I want to
guarantee that my booking is actually
going to get reversed so other customers
the advantage of a process manager is
that essentially it gets the response
back saying I failed to take basically
the credit card correctly and it will
keep retrying that's health directing
service that hey you need to cancel her
booking all right and then in return can
then basically send a message out which
basically says hey customer please
represent when you credit kind of
details so in other words if I require
quite strong guarantees around basically
compensation for I may end up with
basically using a process manager and
release the business decision as to kind
of what happens just now if I was
playing some people the other day they
just eat for example what happens is we
don't control all of the deliver it's
something that happens by individual
restaurants and that happen
third party careers have additional
proportional happens our own careers and
even then even once our own careers we
can't guarantee they're always going to
press the back so we quite often don't
know whether food can deliver to your
house right and so what we actually do
is we assume through he's been delivered
if we don't hear after a certain point
the food's been successfully delivered
to your house why would we do that well
because your tend to phone us out and
complain if you haven't got nothing so
we don't really need this kind of
guarantee or some kind of process
manager because we assume issue while
the business process that a human being
will actually deal borås the other kind
of model that essentially process
managers are particularly useful for
when it comes to pay quite a lot in the
hotel industry is the reservation so the
owner of the reservation pattern says a
lot demand for rooms that I want to make
sure that I don't have some room in some
kind of suspended we didn't take a
payment state for long I want to make
sure that the transaction gets completed
or else we make the river bed with
somebody else so typically what might
happen is the user making the booking
and when the booking starts we start a
kind of a timer so generally there's
some scheduler Hertz running the process
manager which says it's booking author
of completed in this timeframe as we go
through the rest of the process if for
some reason we get a failure to actually
basically reach the end perhaps for
example we didn't get all the details
needs from the from the customer to
complete the credit card payment portion
of the work then we can timeout a given
transaction and then reverse the book
and that then frees that booking up for
somebody else
so if you try and buy a ticket so
basically you know the movies or
effectively for a concert you're quite
often encountered reservation booking
and you'll see a timer or screen saying
you have ten minutes to complete this
and again process might just not good
run that one thing to be wary of with
this model is that we are potentially as
soon as we use orchestration back in the
model of an identity service you can
obviously see how easy
would be before the business logic to
end up now custom the process manager
and for us just to have entity services
again which basically we're done okay
and this is the problem in what we were
we call s away to which is often
described as the Enterprise Service bus
we had these tools like BizTalk for
example that sat in the middle had these
workflow tools that could manager build
workflows and run rules
individual logic and what happened was
they he became the center of our
universe the universe was basically
hidden away inside some vendor based
product and the individual services we
were building were very dumb and this is
where this expression small endpoints
and dumb pipes you're see comes from
which is referred to in mind Fowler and
James Lewis is a lot thought works over
at micro services from this idea of
actually that the business logic is
creeping away into the Enterprise
Service bus and really it's an
expression of this same idea we don't
want crumb based entity services we want
services that are based around processes
we want that flow through will tend to
find if you stick the core at the
choreography initially you're more
likely to end up in the pit of success
on the bottom part now if you move to
orchestration just be wary that it could
lead you into the dark side and you and
you end up on the either path or woods
enterprise service possible okay so
caching reference data so let this one
to kind of last because we've all this
concept already and there's also much
more a lot of the gotchas in this the
detail is explored in my talk talking on
venture and collaboration but we could
simply effectively build a cache of data
live and care estate transfer which
contains the necessary credit card
information from the users account so
the credit card payment can access it
and the accounts information then
essentially is the accounts basis a
critical piece of change customers
changed their address customers changed
their surname because they got married
or whatever unless my traditional then
essentially when the credit card payment
comes in were able to effectively read
from the accounts database to get that
credit card information
that's a very simple model again with
your estate transfer and typically what
we have what we call shared collection
data so that's data where activity large
parts of our system tend to access it
account data say for example it just
eats restaurant information it's very
common to replicate that so they'll
essentially just grab it if you need it
and wanted to complete the work in
response to you receiving basically an
event all right and in turn you may
raise your own message and someone may
listen to that so as I say basically if
you want to see some more details to
understand around when cows they
transfer to do we're basically
producer/consumer correctness we get
into pattern and non tail et cetera
please do go and see my very own
collaboration tool which you should
better fine on NDC's list of videos and
I can always dig it out and share a link
in a strike channel after this and with
that we I've done I've got a couple of
minutes for questions and I will hang
around in the slack room afterwards when
I disassemble my studio here and
actually better sit in front of the
computer rather than have to stand if
there are any questions I need to try
and find the chat I have so many windows
open and you kill the presentation and I
can probably find
so the question is I'm reading is how to
make sure the process manager was not
turning to monolith how do you make sure
a person dies that doesn't turn into
basically yeah a horror show basically
becomes a home centralised logic in your
process manager I think the thing to do
usually is process managers work
particularly well in son either he given
microservice boundary and the context
we're talking about there is not
uncommon necessarily to you with inside
of Microsoft Andrey they have a
container that basically has your API on
it container has some worker processes
inside it that basically you're
offloading work to you and if it's
basically within the domain of a single
process itself they work pretty well as
soon as you start to cross multiple
micro services with them you need to
start being cautious and generally it's
kind of okay if it's a fairly
straightforward really what I'm just
trying to do is run a time or a
reservation or really I'm just trying to
make sure that I'm ensuring that
basically the reversal of the
compensation for a failure route it will
be enacted and effectively I'll get
retries if you start to do things like
like conditional logic in there or you
start to have too much knowledge around
complex set of interactions and multiple
micro services that I would start to be
cautious check if you're doing things
like making calls to external systems
and the process manager rather than
letting your micro service to do that
etcetera I would start to be pretty
cautious um I might use your model to
start with choreography and only moved
to a orchestration if there's a problem
with choreographies compensation or
leading reservation panda I guess
I can't so successful choreo I don't
like that one default use events and
then I use commands if effectively I
really can't solve the and that's not
great answer but it's kind of like don't
go there until unless you know that
you're gonna pay a price and some
behavioral coupling in your system which
create bush will create more rigidity
for it nothing else don't quite figure
out how to see where I've got on my
screen I can read the question for you
yeah and if you want hello
so from Bernardo in your opinion what is
the best technology to do the Gateway
that's an odd you to build the Gateway
but a gateway that's a really good
question all depends on your your
platform there are different types of
Gateway out there for something just
kind of engine actual code in there you
end up in jail and you can use things
like history etc effective in that layer
that's a pretty good solution in dotnet
land you know you can get a long way
with using something like quality inside
basically an API layer opportunity to do
a lot of that work for you you're
effectively I think I proxy with your
retry circuit breakers fellow is that
kind of et cetera you may need state
machines in there effectively if you're
just I want you to do that you can if
you get one to do lots of composition of
API you so things like a hello you can
graph QL which can basically let you
combine various rest api's together so
do you work that one we're not really
used to call in annual but it looks very
interesting a graph you're interesting a
choice for doing genuine composition
across multiple micro service API is an
interesting way we'd like a behind it
the back making those calls and
micro-service end points but in terms of
a proxy and I build an API I need for
proxy underlying internally you can just
use anything to basically in your
platform supports building though she
TBA based API and it has logic to some
packages that support things like retry
circuit breaker fall back to a cache
etcetera alright suspect we are close to
tongues you can probably get questions
all this technology none of them gives
me a clock but I got about four screens
and I cannot see a clock or the chat
window anything that's basically a bit
of a fail or somewhere all right I'll
tell what guys I will see you in slack
because I suspect recorded towards the
end I will give me a couple of minutes
to get into slack and I will get in
there and start answering any questions
you've got in there and I'll see you
then thanks thanks very much for coming